hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
I am so excited because today I finally
got my hands on the new samsung galaxy s
9 and a huge thank you to Samsung for
sending me this to review one that I
ordered at the time of filming this
video is not currently here yet I did
order the lilac color for myself so
probably by the time that I post this
video I'm already working on the review
video so stay tuned for that
you guys aren't subscribed already make
sure you hit subscribe and I will see
you in that next video but for now we
are going to unbox the new s9 I can't
wait to try this out I'm so excited that
I decided today that I would match my
outfit with my knife because why not
pretty sure I don't even need a knife to
open this but we're gonna use one anyway
so let's get started this knife is super
sharp my sister got me this for my
birthday oh look at that
completely unnecessary of a cut I think
else I can cut no I don't think so
I've got all of our paperwork ok let's
check it out fingerprint sensor front
and center I love it this looks great I
cannot wait to test this out so let's
set this aside and let's see what else
is in the box because I'm sure you
haven't seen this 9 unboxing yet so
you're probably curious just seen I have
no idea what else could be in there
you've got our charging brick we got our
USB converter we've got our USBC cable
and we have our AKG headphones case you
haven't seen these before you probably
saw them in my note 8 unboxing and
everybody else who was posted won the
midnight black does look really good I
cannot wait to see the lilac though
because obviously it's gonna look
fantastic
yes tonight is official inbox and I'm
about to boot it up and pop in a SIM
card and then we can get this thing
going
[Music]
it's kind of crazy going from the iPhone
10 because it is much bigger and I'm so
used to this smaller form factor that's
a pretty significant height difference
yeah yeah yeah I agree
we're setting up intelligence can face
recognition iris scanner fingerprint
scanner pin or nothing set a secure
screen lock register your face and
irises I don't want to take my contacts
out but I'm probably gonna have to so
hold on okay well now I judge my
contacts out so I can't see anything
well that's it a lot of you guys always
ask what this drink is it is guaiac e
your vermont a I get it at Whole Foods
or you can buy it by the case online not
sponsored I agree it just turn on
everything just let me use my phone
please just do what you want to do you
basically already whoo my gosh look at
this picture of me okay so now my phone
is pretty much set up let's see swipe
screen to unlock and unlock to shop for
products super slow-mo AR emoji this is
what I've been waiting for so right here
is the option to create my emoji let's
hit that her best results remove her
smile with your lips close and give it a
trivet a whirl is it gonna look like me
is it gonna look like me oh my gosh I
don't know I don't know
I'm super
[Music]
what okay it kind of does look like me
oh my god it's creeping me out this is
so weird
it actually does look like me okay I can
change my hair cuz I'd like my hair to
be a little bit longer so there's
different hair options here I also think
that my hair might be a little bit
blonder than this picture but this
actually looks like me and I'm so
creeped out right now especially when it
starts smiling all weird oh my gosh this
is insane
it's just weird that there's not a more
blonde hair color okay well I guess
let's pick our outfit
Oh so isn't this she what is that that's
I don't wear shorts okay that's that's
something that I would probably wear
yeah what do you think I am a
fashionista okay I'll wear that I guess
that's fine you could send emoji
stickers straight from the keyboard oh
this is going to be so so silly this is
weird guys this is freaking weird it
sort of actually looks like me not quite
picking up my face perfectly so here is
some of my a our emoji gifs I know you
guys don't say it as gifs but I do and
so does the person who created the jiff
he pronounced it as jiff he created it
he gets to decide okay I'm gonna text my
sister and she's probably gonna be super
creeped out by this do you think do I
look nice do I look pretty
do I look pretty nice I hear Maddie
barking in the background so one of the
things that I do like about the
super-slow-mo
is there is this little square box right
in the center so it determines when
something is actually happening that it
should take the slow-mo video so let's
try for example so it didn't capture the
first one but here's the second drop and
it captured that one it looks pretty
awesome I'm so excited to try all this
stuff out well guys that's it thank you
for watching this unboxing I just wanted
to do a quick little video showing you
guys the unboxing and trying out the AR
emoji because I was super excited to see
how realistic it looked to my real
features it's accurate enough to make me
feel super uncomfortable looking at an
AR version of myself that kind of
appeared right before my eyes I'm
does any tests you guys would like to
see me try with this leave those in the
comments below and let me know as soon
as this video goes up because probably
by the time I post it I'm gonna be
starting on the review I'm also very
excited to test out the dual aperture in
low lights so that's definitely
something that I'll probably focusing a
lot on new phone who does actually new
phone who dis I feel like people just
say that it's like you didn't really get
a new phone it's just an excuse and I'll
talk to you if I get it
[Music]